bien au revoir fils
je vis ma vie un quart de mile à la fois
rien d'autre n'a d'importance
ces 10 secondes ou moins
la route ouverte
pourrait vous emmener n'importe où entre amis à la
famille nous savons qu'il est un O'Conner mais il est
aussi un Toretto la loi de l'aventure
faisons  c'est pour voir quelque chose de nouveau
que voulez-vous dire dériver juste pour revenir à la
maison la saga de la peur des attaches a
exploré la possibilité infinie de la
route ouverte depuis les rues juste à l'extérieur du
centre-ville de Los Angeles nous vous avons emmené à
Miami nous vous avons emmené à
Megan Republic Rio
Londyn Abu Dhabi et maintenant notre nom est
connu dans le monde entier, nous avons couru
pour la course de vitesse pour l'honneur de dawa
vous a fait dégringoler des verts et des villes des
montagnes et même tomber du
ciel, mais peu importe la façon dont nos aventures se
développent rapidement et  furious est toujours à propos d'
une chose très importante
[Music]
la chose la plus importante dans la vie sera
toujours les gens dans cette salle
saluent différemment notre famille de
personnages font tout les uns pour les autres
et les uns avec les autres pour th  Les millions de personnes qui
composent notre famille mondiale avancent, nous
nous poussons à aller plus loin et à faire
mieux à chaque fois
nous ne roulons jamais seuls nous ne roulons jamais seuls
cette fois, il ne s'agit pas seulement d'être tristes
maintenant, nous entamons notre prochain chapitre, notre
famille sera  défié comme jamais
auparavant par des adversaires qui ne montrent aucune pitié pour
tester ce lien qui nous a toujours
unis
ambitieux le plus divertissant le plus rapide et le
plus furieux Raja
est rapide et furieux
[Musique]